ces images sont celles d'un drame qui a
bouleversé la france il y a dix sept ans
et pourtant les français de l'époque ne
les ont jamais vu entre elles et eux il
y avait la guerre c'était en 1942 le 9
février à 14h30 dans le port de new york
normandie sombre et au milieu des
flammes
par delà les milliers de kilomètres qui
nous séparent et de lui la nuée
rougeoyantes qui le dévorait répondait
comme un écho sinistre à la nuit de
l'occupation
dix sept ans plus tard au large d'une
île japonaise pour les besoins d'un film
une caméra qui probablement l'avait pas
de coeur fait jouer à son tour à
l'ile-de-france son dernier rôle celui
de sa propre mort la fiction dévorer la
réalité
était faux dans ce faux naufrage pour
des centaines de figurants sauf pour 1
seule l'ile-de-france lui même
aujourd'hui sur les chantiers de penhoët
un nouveau transatlantique français
s'apprête à prendre la relève
c'est le france il a gardé un peu du nom
de l'île de france et beaucoup de la
silhouette du normandie pour les
ouvriers qu'ils construisent chaque
minute compte 300 passagers ont déjà
retenu leurs cabines au bureau de la
transatlantique pour son premier voyage
qui aura lieu sans doute en 1960 cette
tôle rivet a beaucoup d'autres mettra
cinq jours pour relier le havre new york
mais il faudra encore beaucoup de jour
et de nuit le travail ininterrompu avant
que la coque de 300 mètres n'abrite les
luxueuses cabine climatisée que vous
rêvez peut-être déjà d'habiter comme
l'un des 2000 passagers sept longueurs
de 315 mètres et est calculé pour que le
france puisse franchir sans engage trois
crête d'un seul coup 8 chaudière
assureront aux france une vitesse
supérieure à celle du normandie qui
avait trente deux chaudières
il sera dit on une stabilité totale
et c'est par ces fenêtres qui
ressemblent à des écrans télévision
couvert et peut-être un jour prochain
défilé comme un angle en panoramique le
port du new york le jour maintenant à
ses proches ou cette carcasse de faire
encore piqué par la rouille ressemblera
à ça
[Musique]
oh
le pack poufre ans est lancé il épouse
et sa mère la mère sans redouter et s'en
saisir et du peuple la mer qui sépare
les nations et qui leur permet de se
joindre la mer pas où les pires dangers
un foehn à ces états mais sans laquelle
il n'y a pas de grandeur
la mission du navire france fera de
transporter d'un corps à l'autre de
l'atlantique qui sommes des hommes
c'est à dire des français et des
activités et foyer de connaître et des
sources de travaux de l'art et de la
richesse en tout temps un pareil rose
auraient été tenus points importants
aujourd'hui il est plus que jamais dans
ce faisceau tousalon l'une des grandes
réussites que la technique française
présentement offre en hommage à la
patrie que ce soit sur terre sous terre
sur mer ou dans les airs
la cérémonie d'aujourd'hui ajouta fierté
que nous avons de la france est
maintenant que 35 heures
et qu'ils s'en aillent faire rassurant
ou faux cul et pour faire du buzz
février
1962 france a quitté le havre pour sa
première traversée vers new york gagnant
la haute mer le navire long de 316 m et
déplaçant 56 mille tonnes atteint
rapidement sa vitesse de croisière
si certains passagers apprécient malgré
le vent le soleil des ponts promenade
les autres préfèrent à l'abri des ponts
couverts entouré des attentions du
personnel se livrer au confort des
chaises longues ou en joie du footing
sur la passerelle le commandant a donné
l'ordre à la machine d'allumer les huit
chaudière spécialement étudié pour une
consommation minimum de mazout
elles vont transmettre au turbo
alternateurs la puissance nécessaire
pour développer 160 mille chevaux et
atteindre une vitesse de 35
quand
c'est une machine fournissent aussi le
courant électrique
c'est par ce tableau véritable centre
nerveux du navire que passent tous les
circuits électriques un seul homme de
quarante surveille le bon fonctionnement
dans toutes les parties du navire sur le
france où tout a été conçu pour le
confort et le bien-être le personnel de
la salle à manger des premières classes
achève la mise en place des tables pour
le déjeuner c'est dans ce décor que les
passagers trouveront la meilleure carte
de tous les navires actuellement en
service
la classe touriste qui peut accueillir
15 cents passagers est aussi bien
aménagé et décoré que la première place
et tapisseries d'aubusson orne le fumoir
dans le grand salon des sièges
confortables un bar et une véranda
permettent à chacun de goûter les
plaisirs qu'ils préfèrent
et pendant que ce couple américain se
détend dans le calme de sa cabine
climatisée
les enfants qui ont aussi leurs locaux
personnels suivent passionnément les
aventures de guignol en mai
et
dans le salon de lecture des premières
classes oeuvre d'un grand décorateur
parisien trois mille volumes sont à
faire aux amateurs de livres
le déjeuner a été annoncé et les
passagers se hâte vers leur part
[Applaudissements]
atos au succès du navy amérique est
proche les messages radio affluent le
france a maintenu sa vitesse près de 33
noeuds
et bientôt en bronze light le bateau feu
qui marque la limite des eaux
territoriales américaines
ne crampes avoir hissé la statue de la
liberté va être passée 8 février 1962 9
heures du matin l'horaire a été
strictement respecté france entre dans
l'hudson river et va recevoir l'accueil
inoubliable que new york réserve aux
grands navires qui pénètre pour la
première fois dans son port
non
un soir t2m de bateaux saluée par les
sirènes survolée par des hélicoptères au
milieu de gerbes d'eau des bateaux
pompes france poursuit sa marche
triomphale vers son quai d'accostage
[Musique]
pour les passagers c'est
l'émerveillement de découvrir ou de
revoir les célèbres gratte-ciels de
manhattan
à l'heure dite le navire atteint enfin
le quai sous les acclamations des new
yorkais
a répondu aux espérances mise en lui
dans un peu plus de 24 heures le norway
aura quitté normalement le quai de
l'oubli ou havre où il est amarré depuis
octobre 74
l'ex paquebot france qui sera tirée par
un remorqueur de haute mer devrait
arriver samedi ou dimanche à brême
là il sera réparé et transformé selon
les voeux de son propriétaire
l'armateur norvégien kloster pour être
opérationnelle la saison prochaine dans
la mer des caraïbes
c'est du moins ce qui est théoriquement
prévu car deux obstacles doivent être
franchies premièrement l'opération
remorquage
le paquebot est aussi haut que l'arc de
triomphe
sa prise au vent est considérable le
risque d chouman est réel et depuis
plusieurs jours les syndicats français
et la cgt en particulier dénoncent les
risques énormes qu'il n'ya de remorqué
le navire comme une épave en cas de
tempête second obstacle
les syndicats eux mêmes la cgt s'oppose
au départ du norway et on ne sait pas
comment
dans les faits cela peut se traduire
georges séguy a écrit au président de la
république pour lui demander de faire
annuler le départ du paquebot le
secrétaire général de la confédération
ouvrière se déclare je cite scandalisé
que les travaux de transformation du
bâtiment soit confiée à des chantiers
ouest allemand et il demande au
président giscard d'estaing que de
nouvelles mesures soient prises pour le
sa remise en état
dans les installations portuaires du
havre
quoi qu'il en soit le capitaine
norvégien commandant le norway a affirmé
tout à l'heure que le paquebot
appareillerait comme prévu à 14h30
mercredi matin si le temps le permet
jour j moins deux pour le départ de nord
ouest france à franklin base de la cgt
wavre ultimes réunions d'état-major à 15
heures aujourd'hui
trois voitures ont sillonné les rues de
la ville invitant la population à ce
rang de nombreuses demain matin à la
sous-préfecture quai de l'oubli c'est le
folklore les touristes dont les plaques
d'immatriculation étrangères ou
françaises témoigne de l'intérêt que
l'on porte à l'expérience de tous les
points d'europe en veille c'est à bord
du paquebot sous l'oeil bienveillant des
policiers marchand de glaces et de
photos ont vu là une occasion de tirer
un profit rappelant leur manière que les
marins et le personnel hôtelier n'ont
pas été les seuls à être victime du
désarmement de france le ministre de
l'intérieur ministre des transports par
intérim a expliqué aujourd'hui la
position du gouvernement à propos du
départ de l'ex paquebot france et de son
réaménagement dans un chantier ouest
allemand s'appuyant sur les deux
éléments qui ont déterminé le choix du
nouveau propriétaire
c'est à dire les meilleurs délais des
travaux et les écarts de prix
considérable et il
monsieur bonnet condamne certaines
interprétations tendancieuses liés à la
transformation du noroît à l'étranger
non seulement écrit-il
le gouvernement n'a cessé de veiller à
donner toutes leurs chances à nos
chantiers dans la compétition mais il
vient en outre de prendre des décisions
concrètes de nature à soutenir l'emploi
actuels et futurs des industries navales
à wavre une question reste pourtant
posée selon le correspondant dans la
région havraise c'est d'ailleurs celle
qui revient le plus dans les
conversations pourquoi un armateur
français ne pourrait pas faire ce qu'un
hors vézien semble pouvoir a priori
réalisé voici un premier élément de
réponse
il tient en un mot rentabilité tout
d'abord les investissements c'est à dire
avant la mise en service du norway h à
80 millions de francs environ
transformation 190 millions c'est un
minimum coût total 270 millions
amortissement annuel 27 millions on
table sur 10 ans de service le norway à
17 ans la durée de vie d'un tel paquebot
généralement de 25 en dix ans c'est donc
un maximum à ses 27 millions
il faut ajouter 7 millions au titre de
l'entretien coûts annuels 34 millions de
francs au chapitre du coût
d'exploitation pas de chiffres précis
mais on relève une économie de personnel
l'équipage du france 15 cents hommes
sera ramené à 7 cents à bord du norway
de plus il sera fait appel en partie à
du personnel étranger donc moins cher
une inconnue le prix du carburant même
avec les transformations entreprises sur
le paquebot le fuel coûtera de plus en
plus cher et c'est là que réside le pari
concernant la rentabilité du norway
9h40 nauroy est enfin prêt à entrer dans
les cluses une écluse donc de 350 mètres
pour le plus long paquebot 315 m bien
des manoeuvres délicates pour les
abeilles qui nous ont cessé de les
multiplier à lapproche même de les
cluses on les a vus peu avant observé
les gérard est ensuite elles ont repris
et à l'avant toujours la bei provence
qui elle tire le nord
mais revenons à hier soir hier soir où
les curieux cet art depuis longtemps que
ces derniers jours a même heure on sait
que les remorqueurs hollandais sont en
vue sur la rade
mais ils ne gagneront le port que plus
tard sécurité oblige
une arrivée très discrète seul est
perceptible le roulement des machines
les remorqueurs se succèdent à cinq
minutes d'intervalle
l'abeille nederland tout d'abord
bretagne et tourne à quatre ils vont
ceux disposés autour de du norway il est
environ minuit lorsque celui ci
s'apprête à démarrer en termes du métier
le décalage qui va débuter après
l'opération de des doublages qui
consiste à retirer les amarres 35 ammar
a retiré les mineurs ouvriers
spécialisés de ce travail s'exécute mais
en raison d' incertitudes
météorologiques l'opération est ralentie
entre temps des militants cégétistes
manifeste vers 5h45 tout de même le
commandant du norway donnera l'ordre
d'appareils l'évacuation des militants
se fait sans heurts et bon vent jusqu'à
lécluse les clues ce que franchit le
norway il n'y aura plus de problème pour
traverser les autres bassins
à autun du sémaphore norway va saluer le
trois coups de sirène il ne lui sera pas
répondu ou si peu quelques bras
s'agitent un fichu bleus que l'on
balance quelques instants la seule note
colorée du départ la marseillaise en
réponse qu'on écoute tombera au bout de
la jetée
alors que les slogans qui suivront
n'auront pas de suite
ultime sursaut organisée par les
militants cégétistes et communistes ce
qui domine l'impression d'un silence
profonds et lourds tandis que s'apaisent
des rumeurs dès que
on s'impose tout
car il n'existe plus que huit tous se
tait pour quelques instants seulement
bientôt le public re devient photographe
et bavard pas tout le public qui
lèverait des visages crispés des
expressions figées des pleurs disent
parfois il n'y a pas eu que des curieux
pour la duo france
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]